hit from ashkash thank you Mike Tyrese
the Pacers aren't supposed to be here
right so how'd you guys get this one
back yeah so they tell me we're not
supposed to be here so uh I guess
they're not they're not right but um you
know we just had found a way to win we
had to dig in figure how to get stops
that third quarter there we knew it's a
game of runs we knew they were going to
respond so uh we just had a run of our
own when you had to lock in defensively
you did how did you keep Giannis how did
you keep Dame who was getting hot how
did you keep them from beating you uh
just keep off the free throw line both
those guys pose a big threat cuz they
get to the free throw line a lot if we
just defend and show our hands and don't
foul um you know we can get the rebound
and get out and run so uh we were able
to do that today after that three that
you hit you looked to the crowd and said
what time is it and then you answered
it's my time why is this your time tyres
uh not mine it's it's ours it's ours for
the take it um you know we're not
supposed to be here expectations aren't
there uh we just we keep shocking the
world so uh we got to watch the game
tonight and be ready for who's next you
said you're shocking the world what are
you showing people what are you showing
NBA fans around the world right now
about these Pacers team yeah I mean
we're fun we're energetic um and and you
know I just want to prove that that's
not a fluke we can do this every night
as long as we get enough stops uh we're
really hard to guard so uh we just got
to figure it out good luck in the final
game we'll see you there apprciate it
thanks all right Lisa the growth of this
star the growth of this young team third
youngest in the NBA they remain
undefeated in the inseason tournament
and they will play for the NBA Cup on
Saturday against either the Lakers or
the Pelicans
that